[Music]
i want to talk to you about something
the what you call the bio fields
phenomenon
it fascinates me can you explain to us
first of all what is the bio fields
phenomena your state of consciousness is
instantly reflected in your state of
biology so if you're feeling peace
harmony laughter as you're now and love
then you radiate an electromagnetic
field that's coherent and all our
electromagnetic fields are interfering
with each other so that's why we're all
feeling so happy you can measure these
instantly in fact we have a study going
on right now at our center where you can
instantly measure
this biofield
through remote control through
biosensors
transmit it to a cloud a supercomputer
and instantly gauge a person's
psychological state so there are people
obviously you can walk into a room and
we've all experienced walking into a
room and something just doesn't feel
right there's a there's a negativity in
the room when i walk into a room
everything feels right
[Music]
yes okay for you
for you deepak when you wherever you go
there is bliss in harmony i'm saying
when i walk into a room everybody ceases
to feel hostility which i sense in you
by the way
you sense hostility in me right now i
was watching all those
things you did to poor jordan
jordan schlansky the guy that works on
our show i talked to you it's a regular
uh segment we do on the show i do a lot
of things with jordan schlansky he's a
producer i saw some things we have some
photographs here i think yeah i think we
have well this is you brought these this
is me i put a camera in his office
because he came in late yeah you're
you're spying on him yeah what's the
next one
this is me i took away his coffee
machine because there you are i paid for
it with company money and i took it away
passive aggressive
okay what's the next one uh this is me
spraying
hand lotion into his desk that's a
childhood rage childhood rage no i'm
lubricating the interior of his desk
nice excuse me and what's the next one
and this is i made him take off his
shirt oh you're just jealous of his good
looking body
you know you're very uncomfortable in
your body so that's uh why do you say
i'm uncomfortable in my body
what do you say i'm a comfortable guy
take off his shirt um he talks a lot
about how much he works on his abs so i
had him take off his shirt and show us
you know what he's got
excuses
but why does that make me uncomfortable
in my own body i think i think you need
to apologize to jordan since he's not
here i've looked for him he wasn't here
today he was actually in a slight vespa
accident
in front of the whole world
since we are influencing their biofuels
he's a douchebag listen
we are
we bought a coffee machine with company
money so and then charged it to me you
know
the world is as we are you're projecting
your anxieties and your issues on him so
i would like actually if you want to
influence everybody's bar
why don't you just say dear jordan dear
jordan can you say
yeah okay dear jordan i'm sorry have you
hung out with jordan by the way
i
haven't honestly i'm just okay i'm going
to do this now and then you're going to
hang out with george
dear jordan
dear jordan i'm really sorry for
projecting my psychopathology on you
i'm really sorry for projecting my
psychopathology on you i hope you will
forgive me
i hope you will forgive me cheers
cheers and best of at your new job
whatever that may be
i'm comfortable in this body feel that
that's
later